[Music]
all right let's go to rachel in
nashville tennessee rachel what are you
doing how's it going
it's going great john thank you for
having me here thank you for calling so
what in the world you're in my
neighborhood so i'm going to be extra
nice right
um so what's going on how's it going i'm
from california oh
it's on now
uh actually you're helping all of our
real estate prices so i'm glad you're
here too so what's up how can i help
so i've been struggling all my life with
anger and violent thoughts and
that's led my husband to be
uh become
from a kind and patient person to
kind of short and stressed out all the
time
okay
so you've been wrestling with no is
there
violent and
angry thoughts for most of your life
yes tell me about these violent thoughts
it's usually
out of like morbid curiosity of you know
what would happen if i
you know shot everybody or
killed some people with a knife i'm
holding and
uh
even walking into the room it's like how
you know how many people could you get
away with killing before people notice
you're doing it
or
it
to
solve problems my first thoughts turn to
i could just punch somebody and it can
totally end the conversation right now
okay
and then what is what has that what does
the anger feel like where does that come
from
i
i get i'm gonna just assume it's just
from
my mom was a
very tense person okay
she wasn't when i was younger you know
so much but she was very
quick to anger
and it got worse over the years as i
grew up
okay and
that just led to me seeing anger solve
the problems because nobody really
wanted to
um you know
argue with her okay and deal with they
would just let things go deal with the
relationship stuff okay
and so now you're married what else have
you
struggled with have you struggled with
um
anxiety before have you struggled to
deal with any sort of past abuse do you
deal with hallucinations like what else
are you are you working with here
i do deal with a lot of hallucinations
that's happened i can remember past
when i was five years old
i've been dealing with them okay i have
had insomnia for a long time but i never
knew it was my mom assumed i was
sleepwalking but in reality i was
actually
you know i would get up in the middle
night when people weren't awake and i
would wait till they were all asleep and
then i would sneak out and go
crawl around the house and
play with the cats or
actually sneak outside and go wander
around the neighborhood and quietly come
back in my mom doesn't even know i would
sneak out okay when's the last time you
had hallucinations
yesterday last night
tell me about it
it starts out with voices i think i hear
somebody whispering to me and
i can't clearly hear what they're saying
now now i just ignore it to the point
where i don't even care what they're
saying and
then it turns into
i thought i saw somebody walk into my
room or there's somebody outside hanging
out my window
i just learned to ignore it okay
but if my husband's not home i freak out
and will not sleep because
it gets worse because he keeps me
grounded if i
if i get too
worked up at night where it's getting
really bad and all i can hear is just
screaming and
you know
voices in my head i can cling to him and
know okay he's real everything's real
gotcha we're fine so when you're in
relationship
um
you you can you you understand there's a
gap between what you're experiencing and
what's truly there and when you find
yourself by yourself
as we all do right um
those fears
whether they're thoughts or no i can
actually hear that or i can actually i
just saw that shadow i just saw that
trailer
my heart is racing as though somebody is
looking out the window right your body
starts to react for you right um that
gap between what i'm feeling in reality
disappears
and your body says we're not safe right
we got to respond
yeah okay have you
been medicated for this before have you
gone to see somebody
no not at all um before my you know the
you know uh i did have seizures in the
past and
the they were small uh petite mall
seizures and
the
whole
i would see things people wouldn't
wouldn't hear about was just left to hey
you're little and you have an active
imagination right i just learned to keep
it quiet because at the time my parents
my mom wouldn't deal with mental issues
very well sure
so what i want to do here um well let me
do this before i start just pipe in here
how can i help are you calling about
this like what to do next or
tell me what's your question
my question is is there a way i can
cope first and first with my anger
because my anger just
blows up and my kids are getting afraid
of me because i will just start
screaming at them and then i catch
myself and just like calm down calm down
they didn't do anything
and
i'm
trying to figure out what can i do where
it doesn't happen anymore
uh because it just i black out yeah
so number one
what a great mom who's thinking i need
to stop this i don't like where this is
headed
so good for you okay
um that tells me you've got some at
least one foot on the ground in reality
right
and you have a picture of where you want
to be and you also don't have the tools
to get there right now so good for you
for just stopping and saying i need to
get some help okay
um
when i
the best way i can describe this tell me
if this if this hits home
there become moments
that
you're trying to hold your thoughts
and what you're seeing and or
experiencing right without smelling
hearing
and the thoughts
and the actions that you know you're
supposed to be doing it feels kind of
like you're trying to hold soup in your
hands
and most of it keeps running out but
you're trying to keep it together but it
just jumbles all together and you're
holding some pieces but it just is does
that make sense it just starts to slip
away
yeah it it really does i often feel like
i'm on a razor's edge between reality
and sanity and i know that
if i slip down to insanity i'm not going
to easily get back
that's right that's right so
um
i got some good news for you and some
challenging news okay
the good news is
there is healing here
i think
okay
given your child this has been going on
for a long long time
given that you've got a history of
seizures
given that you've got a history of
um
what i'm gonna guess is a pretty
challenging childhood
nothing you're telling me is surprising
okay nothing you're telling me is
freaking me out
i will tell you that the way you have
been able to articulate what's going on
in your mind and in your heart
you need professional psychiatric care
today
okay
and so the violent imagery the i wonder
what if
on top of anger that can lead to
blackout and there's young kids in the
picture and sometimes i can stay
tethered and sometimes i can't in the
hallucinations
plus your history of epilepsy it's time
to go sit down the psychiatrist and say
here's what i'm experiencing
and the challenge is that it's what
you're experiencing is a very real brain
issue okay similar to you were lifting
weights and you your elbow broke or you
were playing soccer in the front yard
and you broke your ankle
nobody would look at you and say hey you
have a moral issue
you got bad character if you go to a
doctor no they would say hey you got to
go sit down and see somebody let them
know what's truly going on
and the the pharmaceutical interventions
on these things are so
remarkable
here in the 21st century
um and
it's time for you to go do that work
okay and i know that it's scary to say
out loud with somebody because you think
they're gonna take your kids away or you
think that they're going to
take your control of a situation away
and what i'm telling you is
depending on the nuances of your
situation i'm not hearing that now but i
am hearing that you got to get help
here's what anger is anger points us
towards something that we care about
anger is our body's way of saying this
is really
important to me and it's not the way
it's supposed to be
and your body is going to continue to
respond in that way because it is trying
to make sense of
reality and non-reality all at the same
time
okay
and the more that there's that divide
and as your kids grow up they're gonna
do things that don't that you don't
wanna do that's just parenting right and
your husband's gonna have these
experiences and the world around you is
gonna have these experiences gonna be
stimulating and overwhelming
you gotta go get the help that you need
and so here's what i'm asking from you
rachel would you commit on behalf of you
on behalf of those little ones of a
husband sounds like he's loves you all
right
will you go call somebody today and say
i need to come in and just
tell you what's been going on in my
whole life will you commit to that
yes
you're worth that
and you live here in my community you're
worth that
does that scare you does that make you
nervous is that a relief
i don't know it's
i guess i'm unsure of if i you know
finding the right person to work with me
sure
i
have trouble talking to a lot of people
um
usually it wears me out and i just want
to go home and that's right
be
you know just with my family or in my
own little place that's exactly right
that's right
and so it's going to be a risk and it's
going to be scary
and what i want you to know is
you're worth a life
without that dark imagery
and you're worth
being able to be in your own home and
that be a place of peace not a place of
terror
and you're worth not having blackout
anger fits
and you're worth having kids who aren't
scared of their mom because deep down
you're a good person and you love your
family
i i try trying to be a good person and i
do love my family i know you do i know
you do i know you do
the person i want you to start loving
that much
is you it's rachel
and that starts with the first time in
your life
for the first time in your life
going to see somebody and saying hey
um i need to get help
i need the voices to stop
and what i'm telling you is you live in
a great city with some great resources
whether you start with your um
employee handbook
whether you pick up a phone book and
call vanderbilt psychiatric
whether you
call a local counselor and say hey i
need some help and i know this is going
to be bigger than just some uh something
a local counselor can help me with
but i need to go get some help
but you need to do that today
you can do that today
thank you so much for your vulnerability
rachel i know this call was hard
um thanks for being willing to tell the
truth and be open
and now i'm looking forward to seeing
what the next chapter in rachel's life
what healing is gonna look like for your
brain i know you're exhausted what's
gonna look like in your family what's
gonna look like with your kids with your
husband all of it and that starts with
you calling a psychiatrist
and saying i need some help
thank you so much for your vulnerability
rachel